big cannon made sure that men's fashion
week got off on the right foot
this morning and York in a how Nick
Warrick here a two million dollar shoes
your boy for the Perry Ellis
presentation on me check those now I
like your style there's no wear it 2
million oh these are the Reebok treasure
yeah don't tell anybody we talked to
Nick at his fitting a flair a turban and
he cleared up all those rumors about his
divorce from Mariah why he still hasn't
signed those papers two years after the
split there were so many rumors out
there like I was holding something up as
I'm mad you know that it's clearly not
the case who made that up who put that
out there
those rumors hinted that by not signing
the papers yet he's keeping Mariah from
time than not with billionaire James
Packer I wish it was that easy or you
could just sign something to be like I'm
done but I it's a lot of things that go
with that they are beyond my control
only thing that's important to me is my
children you know and I want I want
what's best for them and you know I
believe my ex feels the exact same way
again you gotta you gotta respect the
process so luckily you know that's all
behind us now and everybody can move on
and be happy and that's where we are but
their split didn't seem so friendly last
month when he released this rap title
divorce papers I happen to the brains
this she's playing a mouth the time that
you spend with your own kids
it's called visitation son
that was more eventing process of like
showing people like what this you know
last two-and-a-half to three years has
been going on in my mind and you know
I've never really been able to be so
personal on that level so I wasn't upset
with anyone I mean like I said I was
upset with anyone I was upset with the
process well there was no sign of that
frustration as Nick attended the Perry
Ellis show nothing but smiles and style
man I'm so excited I've actually had a
long relationship with Perry Ellis so I
got it come here and get dressed and get
off fly